你必须要承认人家对家庭的贡献，
你心里才能平衡，
否则的话，
你老想着他比我矮6公分，
老想着他为什么不哄着我，
你的内心世界的秩序不平衡，
你怎么可能跟他好好相处呢？
你必须在你自己的内心把你自己的内心的秩序搞顺了才行。
我32了，
他30，
在小县城体制内每个月4000，
他在单位是每个月5000~1万不等。
我们认识一年，
结婚3，
在结婚五年了，
有一个男孩儿三岁，
他的情况就是他身体不行，
并且情商很低，
脾气比较犟，
日常生活说话又比较难听，
情绪不稳定，
吵架的时候他会情绪失控，
但是也没打过我，
平常比较爱生气，
就是不会包容我一点，
喜欢在父母面前告状给他一块儿出去的时候，
有时候他老是有事儿给他在总结他，
安抚他的休息，
他的优点就是工资都会上交，
挣多少钱都会给我，
然后平时心力好的时候也愿意，
可也会给小孩玩，
看孩子，
平常也做家务，
洗衣服，
平时我上班时间不算太忙，
我有有时间就会在家带孩子，
做家务，
做饭，
我的缺点就是经历的事情比较少，
有些事情看不明白，
有事情发生了时候不知道怎么处理，
这个就说话比较直，
不会来晚的，
但是我性格也比较柔弱，
就是有时候不敢跟他硬刚，
哎声闷气，
我们。
就是平常经常吵架，
我也比较内耗，
去年又查出了乳腺结节，
有多个乳腺结节，
他觉不住任何情绪，
只有在我情绪好的时候，
我们才能平均相处，
就是我有情绪，
他情绪更大，
就会发脾气，
吵架。
有时候呢，
我的负面情绪又无处发泄，
不能在他面前表露出来，
我就会向孩子发脾气，
无缘无故发脾气，
我也不喜欢这个自己的状态，
不知道该怎么去调整，
我们也尝试过，
就是沟通，
但是沟通不了，
他就是属于逃避性，
我能量越来越低，
吵架他也从不认错，
不说软话，
就矛盾的时候他就是轻者就是打自己耳光，
重则那就是离家出走，
现在就是说辞职威胁，
然后去外地之前他老是维护他父母，
在他父母告状，
比如他会在他妈面前说，
我觉得他妈做饭不好吃，
这一类的话，
就我心里也有结，
吵架的时候有啥多，
我感觉就过不下去了，
我没有一个房子是60W，
然后车呢，
就10，
之前说离婚的时候孩子给我，
房子也给我，
但是他又不同意了，
我不知道这段婚姻还有继续的必要吗？
我们现在农村住，
我也舍不得孩子，
没有人帮忙带娃，
并且父母也不支持我离婚，
不离婚的话不知道该怎么过下去，
怎么相处，
怎么能调整自己的状态。
在内后，
想着怎么样能给孩子创造一个更好的环境，
平时俩人不说话，
冷战或者是吵架的话，
还不如就一个人带孩子，
给孩子一个就个平和的环境比较好。
你现在想象一个场景，
想象一个就像平行世界马上要发生的事情啊，
假设你老公今天走了，
你的日子会更好过吗？
你的钱够用吗？
你的孩子会得到更多的资源吗？
会有人保护他吗？
就是假设他今天就了没了他了，
你的生活会更好吗？
不会，
也就是说你需要他，
你需要他的钱，
需要他保护孩子。
社会资源你需要他，
孩子也需要他，
没有什么社会资源，
主要是孩子需要他，
就是跟他玩的时候，
我感觉孩子也是比较开心的，
就是说钱你需要他吧，
他一个月挣5000~1万，
你一个月挣4000，
你是需要他的钱吧，
但比我更好一点，
对孩子也是需要他的吧，
他是不能死的吧？
对，
但是老话的时候就很内后，
还是那句话，
姐妹啊，
情绪这个东西最终是向内求的，
你不要觉得他跟我聊天，
我才能高兴，
他哄我，
我今天才能过日子，
他对我态度好，
我今天才能开心。
不是的，
情绪的世界里面只有我一个人了。
我决定我今天要好好的对孩子，
我就好好的对孩子，
我决定，
我今天要和颜悦色的对父母，
我就和颜悦色的对父母，
我决定。
我今天要这个面带微笑的对待我的客户，
对待我的同事，
我就要这么做，
而且你知道吗，
你的表情，
你的肌肉可以欺骗你的大脑，
如果你每天表情是快乐的，
眼里是带笑意的，
会欺骗你的大脑的。
你们不要以为龙飞姐释瞎说啊，
这是有科学依据的，
我直播间有没有学这方面的，
你的表情，
你说的话会欺骗你的大脑的，
就如果今天此时此刻挂了电话，
你就说我今天我决定我要高高兴兴的过这一天，
我决定我要面对微笑的，
面对我的领导同事，
面对我的孩子，
你就慢慢要去欺骗你的大脑。
还有一个就是我一直就是老是嫌弃他个子比较矮，
然后脾气不好，
害有怕身体不行，
我就基本上没有夫妻生活，
我不知道这种嫌弃应该嘛，
不知道该怎么调整自己的身体状况，
这种简单粗暴的方法，
除了他之外，
你能找到更好的吗？
你能找到比他收入更高的吗？
在这个农村教育的这个地区，
他收入应该是偏高一点，
就是说你你离了他之后，
你现在带着个孩子，
还能找到跟他一样一个月收入1万块钱的老公吗？
这个我也不确定，
把你的通讯录打开，
所有的异性全点出来看一遍，
应该没有吧？
好，
既然没有的话，
它就是我的最优的选项了，
那我也得看看我自己有啥，
我自己是那种皮肤特别好，
身材特别好，
特别漂亮，
头发特别。
些茂盛，
一看就特别引人注目的女性嘛，
如果我不是，
那我要降低我的期待，
因为我比她高了6公分吧，
高6公分，
你当初是为啥要选她呢？
当时结婚的时候就觉得她个子有点矮，
但是没想到之后最让我受不了他不是她身体不行，
而是她那个脾气问题，
脾气比较暴躁，
然后情绪又不稳定，
吵架的时候情绪失控，
她不会哄一点儿，
反而你在吵架的时候要哄着他，
就吵架过后要有时候要先跟他说好话，
起码相处的时候你情绪不好，
他情绪更不好，
你好的时候他才能情绪稳定。
那你想问我啥问题呢？
如果不离婚，
应该怎么相处，
把日子天天渐渐的过下去，
首先啊，
在自己的心里要明确的去承担自己当初的选择带来的结果，
因为他不是今天才变矮的，
他不是跟你结完婚了之后一下子矮你6公分的，
当初他就是矮你6公分的，
你当初之所以选择一个矮你6公分的男人，
肯定是他收入比你高，
他经济条件比你好，
你肯定当时也是权衡过利弊的，
既然当时已经权衡了利弊了，
今天就不要再找后账，
他如果说个子比你高，
收入又比你高的话，
那就轮不着咱了，
你不能找后账，
你这找后账的话，
哪个心理咨询师来了也治不了你这个后账，
你不可能说给他腿打断，
给他6公分接上去。
现在情况也。
啊，
身体不行，
你自己又说你不想跟他离，
你想跟他好好过下去，
对不对？
那怎么才能跟他好好过下去？
你只能是看他的优点，
你才可能跟他好好过下去。
如果你一方面又嫌弃他个子矮，
又嫌弃他脾气不好，
又嫌弃他情商低，
又嫌弃他那方面不行，
那我问你天王，
老子来了也不可能跟他好好过下去，
你只有说把注意力看到他身上的优点，
你才有可能跟人家好好过下去。
优点是什么？
人家顾家呀，
人家挣了钱了都交给你了呀，
人家对孩子负责任啊，
人家有一份正经的工作，
而且人家工作收入不低呀，
在你们当地的话，
已经算是超过了平均水平一大截了呀，
你的物质条件不差呀，
你得只能看这些优点，
你才能把日子过下去呀。
咱该说不说啊，
如果咱离了的话，
咱离不开孩子，
咱得带着孩子过，
咱要是离了，
带着孩子的话，
不好找对象，
但是他如果说离了，
他不带孩子的话，
他一个月有1万块钱的工资的话，
他可好找对象了，
哪怕她个崽是不是，
哪怕她身体不行，
一定好找自己生的，
现在好多姐妹就是要那种身体不行的，
你不信我让你看一下我直播间有多少姐妹就想要那个身体不行的，
就想要那个不过夫妻生活的，
扣一，
只要她给钱，
她一个月挣1万块钱，
他交给你，
但是他不跟你过夫妻生活，
你愿不愿意跟他过，
愿意跟他过个扣一。
现实摆在这儿，
就是那句话，
咱要是离了，
咱一个月工资4000，
咱带着个孩子，
咱可不好找对象，
他要是离了，
他那方面还不用伺候他，
他还想交工资。
他找个对象，
他身高一米六六还是六八，
然后我身高一米七四，
你老说这个，
那也不可能把你腿打折，
打成他一米六六那样啊，
你俩身高就摆着了呀，
老说这个还有啥意思呀，
现在主要就是是一方面需要我自己去调整，
一定是这样，
你每次想的时候，
你就今天啊，
对我来说有哪些坏处，
钱到不了我手上了吧，
一个月一万块钱的工作拿不着了吧，
他没法陪孩子了吧，
我就得天天陪着孩子吧，
所以他不能，
他活着就是好处，
活着就是他的优势，
每天都得想一下他对家庭的贡献是什么，
一个月一万块钱是不是贡献，
顶老个大的贡献了，
天大的贡献了，
他陪孩子是不是贡献，
他在以后相处的，
我要感一下情绪比较积极的一面，
多给他积极的这个反馈，
其实有的时候啊，
把自己的心养好了，
一切都能好，
就像我课程里面给大家讲过一个故事，
那个故事真的太经典了，
这个故事就是说一个牧师，
他正在准备明天的演讲稿，
他不知道明天的主题该讲什么，
那总得演讲，
总得让他的信众就对他的演讲的题目感兴趣啊什么的，
然后他儿子就跑过来，
就老想找他玩，
然后他随手拿起一张世界地图的那个图纸，
他撕碎了，
他扔给他儿子，
他说你把这个世界地图给我拼好了，
爸爸就陪你玩，
他觉得我孩子拼这个世界地图怎么也得要个半个小时20分钟才能拼好啊。
想想我明。
天的演讲题目，
结果他们家孩子5分钟拼好了，
他爸就觉得特别奇怪，
特别意外，
哦，
世界地图哭成这样了，
你怎么5分钟就拼好了？
他的孩子把这个世界地图翻过面来，
是一张人的画像，
他说爸爸，
我把这个人拼好了，
这个世界地图就拼好了。
那一瞬间那个牧师就想到了，
他演讲的题目就一定是你把你自己的世界规整好了，
你把你自己的心规整好了，
所有的关系才能顺，
你的世界才能顺。
你现在需要做的就是在你的内心里面做一个排序，
在你的内心里面做一个承认，
在你的内心里面做一个确信。
这个排序、
承认和确信就是，
第一，
他挣钱比我多，
第二，
他这个工作相对比较稳定，
第三，
他对孩子也比较有责任心，
第4，
他挣了钱还花到家里面了，
他没有在外面乱七八糟的啊，
养别的女人啊，
生别的孩子呀，
没有在外面给我搞外，
这都是他对家庭的贡献，
你必须要承认人家对家庭的贡献，
你心里才能平衡，
否则的话，
你老想着他比我矮6公分，
老想着他为什么不哄着我，
你的内心世界的秩序不平衡，
你怎么可能跟他好好相处呢？
你必须在你自己的内心，
把你自己的内心的秩序搞顺了才行。
坦率的说，
当初你选择人家呀，
是他比你是矮，
但他挣钱比你多6000块钱呀，
一个月多6000，
那你CEO为你，
我只是提了一下，
最主要的我在。
但是他的脾气你看啊，
人有的时候是相互的，
就像镜子一样，
他是不是也感觉到了你对他不满意啊，
是不是也感觉到你瞧不上他呀，
他才会这样啊，
人有的时候跟镜一样，
你再去学一下那个杨老师的撒娇宝典的那个撒娇课，
你多听10遍，
拿笔记本记用到生活当中好不好？
嗯，
好了，
你一一定要听话哦，
你在我这儿花了300块钱，
我希望我今天能让你明白，
一定是你自己内心真正去承认这个男人对家庭有贡献，
对家庭有价值，
对你有用，
你才有可能以一种新的态度去面对他，
才有可能你的关系，
包括亲子关系，
包括跟公公婆婆的关系，
包括跟老公的关系，
才有可能你心态得到一个转变，
你心态得到转变了之后，
你可能对谁都能客客气气的，
对谁都能和颜悦色的，
妻子关系也好一点好的好，
就这样啊，
觉得该甘蔗确实没有两头甜的，
你像那种电视剧上演的，
哎呀，
又是什么集团总裁，
又有时间给你制造浪漫，
又30岁了没有跟别的女人过觉，
就想着你还有一个千金大小姐追她，
她都不为所动，
他就是接受你的一切的坏脾气。
哎，
就好叫一个文化产品，
那不叫现实，
姐妹们能理解吗？
就那玩意儿，
是那些文化人创造出来的一个产品，
是用来消费的，
是供你幻想的，
但你不能。
很把那玩意儿跟现实挂钩，
现实就是权衡利弊，
能占一头就不错了，
他不不没有什么恶习，
没有什么其他的那些乱七八糟的烂事儿，
然后他挣钱了还往家里交，
他还愿意陪伴孩子，
他脾气不好的话，
这事儿啊，
他是一面镜子，
两个人相处的话，
就跟镜子对照似的。
记得点赞关注哦。